we took an in-depth look at the fitness
regimens employed by some of your
favorite Marvel stars with an emphasis
on the diets and workouts they used
leading up to the MCS big showdown
against Thanos Lupita Nyong'o is a
relative newcomer to the MCU her first
Marvel film was 2018 s black panther and
she put in a lot of work to get in shape
we had six weeks of boot camp where they
you know got us all bluffin
fortunately she enjoyed the physical
challenge Nyong'o said it's just gaining
strength stamina and flexibility I had
to get into particularly good shape to
be able to do the stunts the bootcamp
worked and her physical skill as Nakia
is evident it's easy to imagine that her
workout routine for avengers endgame
rests on continuing to train hard and
put on muscle Karen Gillan debuted as
nebula in the guardians of the galaxy
franchise before appearing in infinity
war and endgame and she didn't skimp as
she prepared for the role squats barbell
deadlifts and other weightlifting moves
played a big role in her workout routine
cardio like running and cycling upped
her endurance so she could last during
the long days on set next came martial
arts training as Gillan put it I had to
start from scratch in terms of learning
how to fight to look like I could do
damage to someone finally she
transformed her diet eating protein
shakes apples and almond butter all
helped Gillen get the protein she needed
in order to build more muscle and step
into the role of nebula
it's not ripe Chris Pratt better known
as star-lord to Marvel fans took to
Instagram to share his Avengers infinity
war workout in the videos on his
Instagram stories Pratt took a
three-mile trail run as a warm-up and
then did three sets of 120 yard hill
sprints
Pratt went through an intensive training
regimen for guardians of the galaxy
working for three or four hours each day
and losing 60 pounds in just six months
during that time Pratt also gave up
alcohol ate 4,000 calories a day in a
low-carb diet and did swimming boxing
p90x running kickboxing and even a
triathlon as part of his workout routine
so when it came time to prepare for
infinity war an endgame Pratt was
prepared you knew what it would take and
it seems like Pratt enjoys his workouts
too I can do 40-inch box jumps now
action hero physical stuff jumping that
high feels really good when you get in
shape the world around you becomes
things you want to jump on and climb on
oh my god are you okay okay when josh
brolin first started preparing to play
cable and Deadpool - he went the
low-carb route right away no sugar no
bread no pastas it can be a difficult
diet to follow but it's also one that
can produce results that is much evident
by watching Brolin as Thanos and
Avengers infinity war in addition to
exercising his self-control in the
kitchen Brolin put in the work in the
gym - Gold's Gym according to the
location on some of his Instagram
workout videos Brolin performed drop
sets and other workout moves with his
trainer Justin David Lovato of built
nutrition and training
he's definitely put in the work and
although he can now enjoy his role as
Thanos that role came at a heavy price
cost
[Music]
can you picture Ironman doing yoga that
suit would definitely make it difficult
but in real life Robert Downey jr. is an
ardent enthusiast in 2008 Downey
described his infatuation with yoga
telling time I need a lot of support
life is really hard I've just been at
the ready and when the opening was there
I hit it Downey was in the news for an
assortment of dangerous behaviors many
years ago and he said yoga is a big part
of what helped him improve his overall
health and wellness and stay on the
straight and narrow
yoga isn't a shocking or a particularly
exciting workout it doesn't make
headlines like some of the other intense
regimens other Marvel actors put
themselves through but Downey doesn't
stop there either
I train kung-fu I strength train I do
Qigong I do Susan Downey's workout as
Tracey Anderson by now we're pretty deep
into the Marvel Universe more than 20
movies deep in fact and many of Marvel's
primary actors have been around for a
while that's why they continue working
out all year long even if they aren't
training for any specific film Chris
Hemsworth in particular maintains a
consistent workout routine to stay in
shape for playing Thor when it's time to
really gear up for his next MCU
adventure he can pack on as much as 20
pounds but in between movies he keeps
going to the gym I'll be it at a more
low-key level there's no reason for the
cast to keep up their punishing 6 day a
week workout schedule if they aren't
preparing the film but continuing some
sort of consistent exercise can help
them stay healthy and also stay prepared
by keeping up with workouts they won't
have as much work to do in order to get
back into fighting shape for the next
movie the other funny thing about doing
these kind of you know genre action
movies is you don't want to be the tubby
guy through focusing on year-round
fitness staying in shape all the time so
they'll be ready for the next Marvel
film some of the MCU stars have
developed a life-altering affinity for
healthy living
Chris Hemsworth has even launched a
health fitness and diet app which helps
subscribers set goals and then complete
short focused workouts to reach them I'm
fulness training nutrition general
health and well-being and thought
wouldn't it be cool if I could bring all
those people together into one space and
give you guys access to that team
the rest of us the MCU caste isn't
getting any younger and a persistent
focus on regular exercise and sensible
nutrition is always a great way to stay
in shape whether you're simply staying
healthy or gearing up for a blockbuster
movie like Avengers endgame to see how
more Avengers actors got into shape
watch this video right here plus even
more looper videos about endgame or
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]